in the early 80s milk lakes and butter
mountains had begun to form in Europe
whatever amount of milk farmers produced
the EU would guarantee to buy it at a
certain price but demand lagged behind
to curb overproduction and eliminate
massive surpluses dairy quotas were
introduced in 1984 since the 1990s a
series of reforms to the Common
Agricultural Policy
have led to a more market-oriented
sector with modernization and investment
grants available and farm businesses
more able to respond to market signals
now dairy quotas are being abolished in
the EU this comes at a time when demand
for dairy products especially cheese is
forecast to rise significantly in the
coming years particularly in Asia EU
producers should be given the chance to
benefit from such a trend and allow to
increase their production this is an
enormous opportunity for EU growth and
job creation of course there are
concerns in some quarters about this
change but the c.a.p now has a range of
other instruments to address these such
as additional payments for disadvantaged
areas for more information visit the
europa website or click on the links
below